Let's talk about the rule of law and having
a civilized country with processes that are
adhered to in line with the framework of our
country that includes coequal branches of
government and distribution of powers. The
Trump administration has already ignored.
They are past due on eight impeachment subpoenas.
Now, there are far more than eight impeachment
inquiry related subpoenas that have been issued.
The due dates on some of those have not yet
passed. It's October 22nd however, and I've
been talking about this, what good is a constitution?
What good is the law? What good is a constitutionally
enshrined impeachment process? If the Trump
administration can simply ignore it, but not
only ignore it and get away with it, which
is exactly what is going on. The answer is
all of that infrastructure, all of those duly
enshrined powers of the co-equal branches
of government, they are pretty damn worthless
if they are not going to be enforced and it's
not just Democrats, it's also the judiciary
that is a part and parcel of this. So let's
look at them. Okay. Some of these are document
requests. Secretary of state Mike Palm PEO
was supposed to turn over documents about
Ukraine 17 days ago. He hasn't done it. There's
no consequences. Gordon Sunland, the U S ambassador
to the European union, a major Trump donor.
He has seven days overdue on a subpoena for
documents, consequences, none. Rudy Giuliani
or Giuliani as some people like to say a Trump's
personal lawyer.
Maybe it's not clear. Trump claims not to
know whether Rudy is still his lawyer, supposed
to turn over a ton of documents, hasn't related
to Ukraine. He's in the thick of it, possibly
criminal six days past. Mark Esper, the secretary
of defense. He is six days overdue on a subpoena
for documents. Russell Vought, the acting
director of the office of management and budget
is in deeply with regard to Ukraine. It's
been six days since his subpoena was due.
Um, nothing. Lev Parness and Igor Fruman.
These are the henchmen. These are like Nixon's
Watergate, henchmen. These are associates
of Rudy Giuliani who are five days overdue
on a request for documents, subpoenas. They
were caught literally fleeing the country
on one way plane to plane tickets heading
to the airport and arrested Mick Mulvaney,
Donald Trump's acting chief of staff three
days past due on legal subpoena document requests.
And of course, Rick Perry Trump's now resigned
secretary of energy, a much bigger player
than we originally thought in the Ukraine
fiasco.
He is also several days past due on a subpoenas,
uh, when you are a regular person, when you
forget to comply with a subpoena, when you
opt not to comply with a subpoena, it has
consequences, whether it's a court subpoena
or a congressional subpoena. I know that there
are Republicans playing this stupid game of,
well, listen, you know, court subpoenas are
one thing, but a congressional subpoenas,
they don't really have that full force. Number
one, you're wrong. Number two, the Trump administration
and associates have also ignored court subpoenas.
So if indeed they are two different things,
they have been treating them the exact same
way. When you are a normal person, ignoring
subpoenas has consequences. It doesn't go
away. You get arrested, you're held in contempt.
It's bad. But so far, no consequences exactly
as I suggested to you would be the case. So
part of this is the system hasn't really had
to deal with this degree of flouting of the
law.
What I mean by that is there are not past
presidencies. We are not, uh, looking back
at past presidencies through Rose colored
glasses. It is merely a fact that past presidencies,
unless you really go back to Nixon, have not,
uh, flouted law in the way that the Trump
administration is doing. And to a degree as
legal scholars have pointed out, the system
as it was designed, never presumed that you
would see a presidential administration flout
the law to this degree. That is one part of
the problem, but Democrats are also part of
the problem. It is time for law enforcement
to get involved in enforcing the subpoenas.
It is time for Congress to actually demand
the full enforcement of these subpoenas and
they're not doing it and there's plenty of
blame to go around. It is not just one part
of your entity that is guilty here and the
sickest irony of it all.
It's that if and when Democrats did start
enforcing the subpoenas with force, they would
be called the authoritarians. They would be
accused of using men with guns to enforce
political grievances. They'd be accused of,
listen, you're putting people in jail, you're
the authoritarians, and it would be another
one of these acts of blatant projection. It
would be one of the most authoritarian white
houses that we have seen in a really, really
long time of the pot calling the kettle black.
What do you think? If you're watching on YouTube,
leave a reply. If you're not, if you're listening
to the podcast or watching on free speech,
TV or anywhere else, send me a tweet at [inaudible]
Pacman. What do you think it will take? If
anything and the answer may be there will
not be, there is nothing even hypothetically
that will do it for Democrats to start demanding
the enforcement of these subpoenas. We will
take a quick break and be back after this
with much more including if you want to talk
about authoritarianism. The way this administration
has dealt with the media is at the top of
the list and Donald Trump now telling his
bedtime phone buddy Sean Hannity from Fox
news that he is going to be terminating the
press rights at the white house of just so
happens to be the New York times and the Washington
post. We'll talk about that
after the break.